[Music]
happy birthday you're not special they
know we all want why we're doing it
wrong
you [ __ ] birthday
off we go
now stretch it off
this is the worst birthday podcast I'm
Michael Kosta thanks for listening
everybody really appreciate it we have a
great episode this week we have a great
episode every week it drops Thursdays on
itunes stitcher SoundCloud in the All
Things comedy network this week we have
Sam Tripoli very very funny stand-up
comedian based out of LA friend of mine
everyone's a friend of mine but he's a
fantastic comic he's all over his
podcast punch-drunk sports he produces a
fantastic comedy show called the naughty
show which is just dirty dirty dirty
filth comedy with porn stars and it's
fantastic please check out Sam Tripoli
com just make sure you become a fan of
Sam's because he's always doing
something interesting and weird and and
he does not go the conventional method
which I think you'll learn through our
podcast and through his worst birthday
is also going to be in a movie called
dying laughing which comes out februari
24th is a comedy documentary please
check out Sam Tripoli com Twitter at Sam
Tripoli thank you for all your feedback
guys your reviews and your ratings on
iTunes go a long way thank you very very
much this week I received a very sweet
email from a listener saying thank you
for the podcast I'm not going to share
her name because she didn't want that
but you can always email me Michael at
Michael Kosta com any feedback any
guests that you like or just private
feedback on the show so thank you very
much for that sweet email if you leave
your Twitter handle or your Instagram in
the review on iTunes I will always shout
you out and I really appreciate it so
thank you it goes a long way we're
getting up to like 50 reviews and that's
great it really goes a long way so thank
you very much as always you can find all
of my live dates at Michael Kosta com if
you want a t-shirt that is bright orange
with a silhouette of Donald Trump on it
and it says first orange president
please go to first orange president dot
biz I did not think these shirts would
be as popular as they are but people are
buying a lot of these
when I'm on the road it's like crazy
we're selling out of these silly silly
shirts but they're american-made
american apparel shirts they're very
soft they're very wearable and they're
funny if you like Trump you got a
t-shirt that says first orange president
if you don't like Trump you got a
t-shirt it's his first orange present
they kind of go either way and he is
orange it doesn't matter if you support
him or not this guy's spray tan is legit
okay so worst birthday com that's all of
your worst birthday needs we've started
recording video during these podcasts so
I've got a couple these episodes banked
on audio but coming soon will be the
video of these podcasts as well which is
pretty cool gives it another layer and
that'll be posted on worst birthday calm
as well as our YouTube page which I'm
figuring out right now so look for that
eventually and I want to thank you for
listening I will be in Cleveland
februari 2 through 4 at hilarities what
a wonderful comedy theatre if you're in
the Cleveland area or the Midwest area
all of my live dates are at Michael
Kosta com coming up I'm in Chattanooga
I'm an Asheville I'm in Winnipeg I'm all
over [ __ ] man Michael Kosta calm here is
Sam Tripoli Sam Tripoli calm his worst
birthday thank you for listening to the
worst birthday podcast I'm Michael Kosta
happy worse birthday
[Music]
where do you want me to sit here
wherever you want whatever you want oh
you don't do the video I don't do video
maybe i should huh dude just dump it on
your youtube page yeah I'm till I'm like
I'm the Paul Revere YouTube I'm like
everything ads and flows do like
instagrams I think Instagram video is
gonna be the death of Instagram they
should not have done video because
you're watching these girls you and it's
like a thousand be watch your butcher
Mariah Carey yeah she gets ready to go
strip it's that's all it is I I wish
Instagram although it killed vine the
video so so what would you recommend
that I just set up a set up this video
Aaron love setting up the video they
were saying dude have you ever met heart
of this video so what do you do you just
dump it on dude I do a daily rant on my
thing yeah I put a funny little stupid
video and then when I do a podcast yeah
I'd take the video I throw it on there
and like I'm slowly building it so it's
like yeah but doesn't it hurt doesn't it
doesn't it make you feel shitty when you
see the 17 people watched it no I'd you
don't care because everybody starts I
mean granted Brogan came in there Ronnie
right Ronnie right they had a million
things but right everybody starts with a
little this guy because reason I got
stories my reason I guess far as my
friend Jordan was like a dude I have
this friend of mine he puts out video
every day he start he goes year one he
had a hundred followers after one year
you got to 100 followers like you got
kind of stoked now I've been do like
five or six years he's got over a
hundred thousand followers yeah look at
Kimmy doorman do you know jimmy dore
yeah she has that [ __ ] many political
show he does yeah it's blown the father
it's long i love jimmy dore jimmy dore
is one of these guys that you know you
talk about underrated commedia I mean
this is a funny [ __ ] dude it's blown
up okay you know what it's just about
sticking be inconsistent or checking
with it for me it's just pick what you
want a reality yeah we're going dude
I'll a sham triple head you know that
pick where you want to go what would you
want with your time that isn't one of my
favorite things about you though Sam is
that whether we're recording or not
you're the same dude some some people is
like Oh recording well hey everybody
yeah yeah you there morning
j business [ __ ] sense let everybody uh
so what we gonna say you pick pick what
you want will you invest your time in
yeah yeah I think I instagram twitter
snapchat they're all going to come and
go ebb and flow ok YouTube will always
be there but your Instagram you've made
an adjustment you're trying to throw up
throw up a lot of funny memes and [ __ ]
yeah and I didn't see that from you a
year ago could I figured it out yeah but
but they're great by the way very funny
you're one of the few comics that I
follow and I go I know it's gonna make
me laugh sometimes you get tired of all
the self promotion of anybody who write
so yours I'm like I want to see what
your post gets funny [ __ ] I want to talk
more [ __ ] yeah I'm always like I'll just
gonna blow up in my face sure and of
course it will but that would be the
best thing that ever happened riot but
you you've made the decision to start
making more Instagram means is that
right more Instagram means more are you
too you know it's like everybody every
conflict [ __ ] YouTube God rock you
taking our weekends I like you could say
that or you can figure out what they're
doing up and do it they literally do
it's so easy what they're doing people
almost think it's insulting yeah but
such like hey let's open this thing and
here's a video of us being with unboxing
i mean i 100% em exactly who you're
describing i even went to the YouTube
space in in playa del rey by the way 500
million dollar space amazing they had a
comedy show you know what I did for 10
minutes I yelled at them about how
they're ruining stand-up comedy and it's
like stop bitching and just try to try
to adjust because this is what people
are responding to dude I I have this app
it's a healthy edit videos and I just
guerrilla-style it and I just ran today
and sometimes I'll get 50 views and then
once a while get 3000 but that's within
like the first three months of doing it
with no like no big name thing behind me
right now like my last thing was a long
time gone spike to be so everything now
is just like little little little little
I just started new like kind of once in
the wild podcast I got a lot of love
like this conspiracy theory podcast yeah
so I just took that dump that on there
got a bunch of views on that and it's
just like little little
right yeah we think we are from older
than you but we we company like hold
everything till it's perfect and release
it yeah this new figa stomp-stomp-stomp
have them so they gotta check in with
you every day and that they get into the
the rhythm of checking in with you every
day I I it I a hundred percent so I have
drafts of tweets that I that I don't
send because I one still thinking and
it's like dude stop overthinking it just
[ __ ] send it yeah gone you're awesome
dude you you know there we go you're
just the one you're just the one thing
away from getting where you need to be
and it's gonna have like I did our
project and I that was knocked it out of
the park and what a fun project yeah
well it was a game show that you al
Madrigal jashne azadi master is edit
that's three people you have a three of
us develop it and it was just a weird
way came together and it is like cuz uh
we were actually thinking like hey dude
MLB gray holds for this I'm like hey man
we got this game shows like I got too
much stuff going on I like making too
much money yeah I did I haha [ __ ] what
is it called position mm-hmm is that
something you know you're in the
industry when you're talking positions
yeah oh dude I'm in like I got [ __ ] in
the fifth fourth position what are you
talking about buddy goes my friend just
hit me up and he's looking for game
shows so we perfected the game this idea
and we sent it to him and he's like I'm
sitting with jordy we read it it's
awesome and it just took on there yeah
and then you know just just ran and it
was such an interesting as a month it's
fun it's just such interesting when
you're in there and it's like such
inside baseball yeah like yeah oh this
is what's going on that's going on and
so I just kind of SAT back and watch and
I had to check my ego to lap [ __ ]
like sometimes you gotta let the people
do what they do do what they do correct
and you just gotta let God you can't be
like no I'll put my finger prints all
over this right I gotta be like nope
just let it go the guys were you guys
were it was so fun to work for comics
because you just let the comics become
how it's just like kick go
order yeah yeah we're like be meaner
yeah but but I mean I go listen to it
exactly if anything it was like hey man
this is funny like just be you and and
that's never what anybody says it so
it's like can you try this position yeah
yeah I felt like like at the first year
kind of like what you guys are where I
can't and at the end you were just like
boom it's fun it's it's a game show they
created called squabble for Comedy
Central's branding unit hopefully you'll
see it soon ladies and gentlemen I think
it's gonna be on TV I would love that
before we pressed record you I asked you
about Edmonton and you had said that
people people don't want to hear the
truth well tell me about that we can why
you came to that conclusion you know at
the end of like 2050 I know we're not
there but you know I was doing a lot of
road I was doing a lot of road yeah I
like I just was in Chicago at this great
club called comedy bar but like every
[ __ ] night yeah there is some white
chick always whooa who wanted to talk to
management and just wanted to talk to
management about what about talk about
your age and this girl Kim you know it's
like I like there's I'm a weird guy
cause like if I don't walk a table I
feel like I've lost a little edge dress
but like I want to like yeah like two
weeks ago skywalk like four people over
the week on my god oh [ __ ] get ready for
a high score correct what are you what
are you saying that's upsetting them
nothing but give me some examples of
some of your topics for people that
don't know swimmin belize comedy well
this woman came up to me and I she was
like first talk to management I talked
to her and she literally had the look of
like why did you choke my puppy out that
now look at her face was benefit and and
I go what the problem is she was telling
me like what she's like herzing was why
are you punching down punch up right and
I'll get into that but right and like
she's like you're talking about doing
coke off girls asses and I mean you talk
about how I get here a teacher you
should if you're going to [ __ ] your
students you should teach GED class
because those those kids won't call the
cops because they have warrants out for
their arrest right what yall Tripoli
class come on man assembly class a class
try and uh she just like you got just
gotta learn about you gotta punch punch
up not punched down and I'm like that's
all from your perspective and what your
view of me is and you yeah and when you
say punch up you just basically make
make fun of white guys I said I might be
all of those make fun of white males
that's the only thing we're allowed to
make fun of and it did I got a couple
things I masses so funny thing about
Chicago is like this club is 10 miles
away from shy rack correct the most
murderous city of our country in the
world man I like we're talking like
Baghdad go bowl like we're banging those
kind of numbers out and this ladies
worried about get joke yeah like if you
care so much about the world go [ __ ]
bomb here in Iraq man right well they
always you know you can make fun of fat
people they laugh you can make fun of
Asians being bad drivers they laugh but
then you make fun of something that is
dear to them and now they're offended I
just for the holding Iran show and it's
like technically if you're really going
to be offended on something you've got
to be offend on all of it why don't you
can't laugh at the black people don't
tip joke and and and then not laugh at
the white women by too much Lululemon
yeah you're amazing cry it's all the
same [ __ ] it's there so much fine print
how much fine print i just i want to say
this chick is like you're mad at me
because you specifically don't like me
their son got mean I just do this gay
bar last night I don't know why I just
take every gig I just such a stage [ __ ]
and like I need somewhere was like well
as well as the show it's a downtown gay
bar so you know that [ __ ] which look I I
like I can one and I don't even know we
on the corner and it was just like they
love that I know the Mexican one because
i know i can order this and I did a
Mexican gay bar in it is brutal but
whatever well cuz I because on the show
and the people everybody in the show and
a new book showed wonderful people yeah
it was all gay guys kicks and then me I
was the only straight guy and when I
walk out they know who the straight guy
of course and they're mad the Trump one
they're mad at you and I they think I'm
the guy who shoved them in their lockers
in high school and call them [ __ ] and
I'm not
that guy at all I had a bad drug problem
bro I went deep in some weird ass [ __ ]
dude yeah i was in hotel rooms with
crazy [ __ ] people yeah and i was the
lower companion I'm not judging anybody
nice i've been surfing craigslist
looking at weird should do that's who
[ __ ] i am so I'm not judging [ __ ]
anybody yeah when I walk out there's a
demon any man yeah and it's like for the
way I go if I to the chicken Chicago I
go if that was Louis CK or that was
sarah silverman you would have been
laughing or your ass off because you
have to do an all political practices
and I told him about this was that it is
just simply what makes white women
comfortable yeah with this weird kind of
like an oppression math that they do
you're right it's like oh you're so you
are suppressed for 300 years through
slavery feel free to wreak on everybody
but gay guys you can't make fun of gay
guys well Joey Diaz has that joke where
he's he he's shooting a movie and he's
got to be a gangster and they keep
saying like look you need to be meaner
and angrier and he's gonna you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and they go
beat you know angry and he keeps doing
and then the very last time he says
[ __ ] and they're like you can't say
[ __ ] no I think even said the n-word
any like he's like dropping and yeah I
girl yeah you guys know the joke I'm
butchering it but it's like they're cool
with everything he's saying you're a
[ __ ] and ass pic and all the [ __ ] and
once he says [ __ ] they're like you
can't say I love that joke but so how
does this affect your not going to stop
doing this material I'm not you're gonna
be Sam I'm no matter what I've decided
to get more selective after that gig
last time like yeah I can't mentally
beat myself up anymore yeah how could
this affected you and I first of all
what's what can management do other than
fire you which they're not going to do
because they'd probably love watching
you perform I think I think they do I I
don't even know anymore I just I don't
even I mean like I don't mean like that
well they got about to happen edmonton
yellow is phenomenal those owners are
the best owners in [ __ ] great there i
mean when i first started playing there
every night off stage one of the owners
tammy or a husband would go can you can
you get dirtier they literally said that
to me though
can you get more filthy I think you're
the filthy guy and I'm like I'm just
going up on stage I'm like imma eat your
I'm just a staff was like that was so
much better that's a fun ass club it's
my staff and and yeah yeah yeah but you
know you're playing some of these rooms
are just people oh oh oh yeah and it's
just like why do you want to hear what
you already know yeah makes it go to a
movie and you're like I could have done
this like but but that's what that's
what it's become now twitter is an echo
chamber it's just by the way Google echo
chamber everybody because it when I
someone told me it was an echo chamber
and I googled and I read I was like oh
[ __ ] I was like this is all it is now
we're just finding what we want to hear
well that is what's so awesome about
stand-up comedy is you're gonna go to
the show you're going to hear something
you don't agree with it if it's done
well you're going to laugh at it and it
may challenge you and that's awesome
that's the best that's the whole point
of this country is what is it getting
offended become that's the worst thing
ever in the world all taya outrage is
outrage is hot right now I'm doing a bit
and it's just about how like everyone
thinks their pain and suffering is so
unique correct like their pain and
suffering is talking snowflakes and no
one else understands yeah yeah I was
telling the other day about how like you
know it's like Ronda Rousey lost to her
first fight and went on Alan she's like
him one time yeah I thought about
killing myself and I was like blown away
I'm like one time yeah then I thought I
during breakfast today I mean like on
the drive over here I think about it all
you know yeah it's like you're not
unique yeah and why do you think it what
nothing to me says more about white
privilege yeah then our political
correctness yeah and Masada you should
go talk to management and you are your
view of the world is the is the meter in
which all should be you know that you
know that the hamburger place called
father's office no in Santa Monica
there's also one it they don't do catch
up alright so if you ask for ketchup you
know what they say no we don't do catch
up I just [ __ ] love that they just
decided like a customer isn't always
right we're
we make the perfect burger and you're
not getting cut by your own k I think
you probably could but I just like it's
like the pc thing it's like we're not
apologizing no this is what we [ __ ]
are not want ketchup go to [ __ ] a
different place yeah I love it I told
that chicken for shotgun she'll start um
I go I've been doing common with 20
years I'm never gonna listen anything
you said I love it this isn't about me
yeah hearing from you what I think it
should do this is me just going I'm
sorry you didn't have a good time maybe
next week you'll find a comic you enjoy
I mean I think that's more than kind I
had a woman I do a joke about how to
properly kill yourself with it with a
gun you don't put it under the chin you
don't put it on ice because it you can
he put the gun in your mouth and a woman
came up and she said I'm I'm devastated
my father killed himself your joke is
terrible you're a bad person and I
honestly felt bad you know I don't want
to I don't want to remind her of her dad
killed here apparently her dad killed
himself with a rifle so of course my
joke is causing some [ __ ] I felt bad i
thought i'm sorry didn't like the joke I
said I'm a comedian I'm gonna I'm gonna
do the joke so then she got [ __ ] your
writing should start yelling at me and
then I was like [ __ ] you I was nice
that's the nice thing you can do is be
nice and go sorry to enjoy it goodbye
yeah but once they once they elevate its
but it's just like we can't know at
whatever like we can't do a survey like
what yeah you and I was having a tea
buddy ya like like the thought of like
like your joke is in a different way but
the same thing my jokes like we think
about it yeah and like we got to talk
about it yeah and like I've seen like
like going back to Lucy k the shitties
talked about on stage like he says the N
word and he doesn't say it in an ironic
way its like meant to be like no I call
this guy the n-word and they're like oh
god I and they justified in a [ __ ]
hummus yes like I get to bed like that
lady had a lot of trauma in life yeah
but it's very naive to think that she
that she would think that you knew that
yeah like all Pam's here dad killed
herself let me do that joke wheelchair
but I I have I do a wheelchair bit every
once in a while someone will say hey
there's a guy in a wheelchair here and I
go you don't need to tell me that
because if it's a good joke he's going
to laugh too and they always [ __ ] do
they
always loud i left i uh i remember one
time to Comedy Store there was uh there
was a blind guy heckling everybody and I
walk in and it was you ever walk in you
are where you just know the energies
weird like the orchid have a weird
couple energy and they're like a riot
weird crowd your [ __ ] crowd i'm like
why what's going on there like there's
this blind guy yeah he's in the crowd
and he's heckling everybody and he's
really like making everybody miserable
yeah and they try to deal with them
there be a nice probably so i want to
make it easy he's blind i watch parents
go up on stage and Brett students act in
this guy's like not like literally not
funny blind [ __ ] gay right and of
course brackets to fight eyes a [ __ ]
Jersey Shore uh who said that I'll kick
your [ __ ] ass like something else he's
blind and I initially goes I'm sorry man
and then it just sucks I go I'm gonna
murder I'm gonna [ __ ] kill this yeah
like yeah please welcome center so do
not funny both I jump on this dude and I
start murdering and for the first time
he is smiling the whole show you love
I'm like you're playing hotline and
she's like she's like oh he went blind
looking at your [ __ ] lady who plays go
crazy of course bomber error comes up
and like shits on me by my dom i [ __ ]
took care of everybody he comes on you
take pictures with me he's like thank
you isn't it funny they want to be
treated like a human being and I don't
say they meaning handy I just mean like
everyone deserves to be insulted that's
like that you know that's that everybody
goes around him handing would kid claude
Tosh has the joke about the make-a-wish
kids and i forget the whole joke but he
says the kids loved the joke the parents
not so much but it's about like you
better die you better die soon or
something and the kids [ __ ] laugh cuz
they want it there yeah that's what he
does yeah Sam what is your birthday
October 28 okay how is that right by
Wright by Halloween this one uh I'm not
so much in the birthdays anymore my
girlfriend cares more about first I got
a girlfriend yeah like christmas is
coming up yeah and she's all about it
and she's a [ __ ] Jew yeah tries me
now she's that she's a Jew in the
Christmas she's a junior Christmas and
still [ __ ] annoying so what so we
can't kill Christ anger kiss that's my
[ __ ] led to you guys are you gonna do
Christmas you're gonna give gifts yeah I
mean we do simple give yeah I'm just not
i mean like and birthday like what you
do this last birthday four percent but
my whole thing is like she got me a new
raider hat and i love I have to go okay
generator half katana I get the lobster
roll that's my I got it I haven't done
it to that that's what you did this I
love to do okay so I love to do I I'm
gonna be honest with you I've had a
couple traumatizing birthdays young yeah
you know one was like in Vegas way back
and day when I was 12 college there and
I gotta fight everybody in 10 people
showed up and I like okay what was that
how old were you that I was like
probably like 22 yeah maybe and you were
you were you were doing drugs then or
what I was alcoholic you and alcohol I
was just drinking I didn't get in a coke
till much later on real in particular at
the comedy store yeah you know because i
can't say her name i got in trouble
another podcast but there was an era in
which this chick yeah ushered in a new
era of coke yeah I'm so funny cuz when I
met you I i had i did i guess i met you
in your coke days but i don't i didn't I
never knew I'd no clue yeah maybe I
didn't I don't know I was doing it and I
like yeah I was just I mean like I
wouldn't trade those days for anything
yeah I I don't give a [ __ ] the other my
career got hurt or whatever yeah those
are the golden beige they all are
nothing again I just need one thing to
pop and I'm back in the mid back and I'm
corporate Sam right now I mean do you
think it affected your career I you know
man I don't wonder I always wonder if I
mean do you think I think I just get so
honest on stage talk about what's going
on and that we just live in a pop comedy
time where everything's about [ __ ]
you know we were getting like being a
career politician where you can't have
any flaws or being real on you're just
like you got to be this clean [ __ ]
cut [ __ ] [ __ ] and it's just like
that's our life like well yeah I was
find it so interesting now how many
comics don't drink and I do understand
because i've i've gone you know I like
to drink but I've also gone long period
of time right don't drink and I am more
productive professionally when I'm not
drinking but comics used to be like
flawed animals students and then I was
like they're like fully branded sober
vista and and it is interesting
everything goes like that yeah the money
starts coming into business people come
in and they just changed the game and
then we're all competing with them and
we can't be that that fun real person
anymore unless you sound like Bert
Kreischer who has like this really
incredible niche that he's yeah work so
hard to create which is like I'm a beer
drink and dad i'ma fun dude yo fun
[ __ ] dude yeah but everybody's afraid
because the connotations of cocaine that
light up you're like [ __ ] you nobody
wants to be the crazy blow guy and I was
like dude I love it I thought I love it
so this 22 you're in Vegas you had you
haven't even gone in the drugs yet yeah
but they're leaving the birthday i was
gonna talk i had a trauma tight tell me
tell me the traumatized birthday I was
about 15 years old not as catchy
traumatizing birthday is not as catchy
as worst birthday but much more impact
were spurt this is the worst they
showing up at least I'm 22 in vegas and
i can still get you still got ten people
yeah happy that's all you need that
that's more than enough my rule is as
long as you play full court basketball
you got enough people right no subs but
we're fine 505 so what happens when a
commercial timeouts what happens with
your 15 so I come from upstate New York
ok we're on cortland just outside
Syracuse ok my father's from Binghamton
yeah do Broome County arena there you go
there all the time love it what saw my
first concert there well it's a motley
crew saw a lot of show on earth right
I'll do what's his name who's leads here
Vince Neil just get I remember watching
it and I just want my think he's pissed
jump in the crowd just meeting the [ __ ]
out of guys they're like ah but that was
part of the show that was part of the
show [ __ ] love it then he got time
you lead goes on this big thing yeah
like in it and it's just star in the
middle of the of the [ __ ] crowd he's
got jump out and got run through the
crowd security just what nailing people
trying to grab them and you're like this
is a great crowd show ever my sister
went to see miley crew and she told me
that the whole thing was
the loudest shell on earth and I just
love that because they didn't say best
they didn't say greatest they didn't say
most me they just said we're just gonna
be the [ __ ] last 100 percentage and
it's just like you talk about blow and
craziness oh I'm sure magic bean 19 in
Hollywood before aids and you're just
the biggest fan in the [ __ ] world at
that point are they still alive how is
that dick not look like an acorn Jeff
hey condition all right so you're 15
traumatising birth I live up a little
upstate and my how does your dick not
look like I was born at the same [ __ ]
just riddle I my dad yeah my dad a
tradition was that I'm birthdays yeah we
would go bowling okay me and my brother
and my dad I will his brother older
younger younger okay and that's very
significant to the store ok how much
younger two and a half years okay and at
one point he was the number-one
highschool Bowl in New York State are
you serious i leave in line he could
Bowl he would he would we called him the
white Bo Jackson because he liked the
number one bowler and like one of the
top golfers he could do all the white
sports right and like dominate right any
good ahi good ball my brother got so
good yeah he could bowl with both hands
Wow three hundreds well I was going to
ask you this because I read something
years ago that the 300 was almost
becoming if you're like if you're a
great bowler it's just expected yeah
like you just get 300 s now yeah and
your brother so lanes now and the way
the lanes and the balls and the oils are
as i right it's kind of like on which of
like nominal golf is a great analogy but
it's like you know some people like a
wide receiver they have these glove that
now i love it's so you like he always
seems like it's so hard not to eat you
have to be really bad not to catch I
always wanted that and then we compare
wide receivers today with wide receivers
50 years ago and it's like he was
catching they had one football or they
always going yeah there's one ball that
both teams use it's the things all yeah
exactly so so your brother could [ __ ]
both my brother was in like eighth grade
bowling
grown men's league right like if someone
didn't have nothing my brother hung out
the bowling alley at night grown man
yeah you know I'm talking about how like
espn3 now has every sports are by drunk
white guys yeah bars like and one of
them is bowling and my brother was like
[ __ ] you my love darts by the way I'll
watch the ships car dude nothing beats
armwrestling did they're high-fiving
money right now I would start I would
invest in that because they'll drug test
these dude they could dude come out with
me they all look like the bouncers at
[ __ ] olympic gardens and that's it
that's and they're just all jacked up
I'm guarantee you everybody there is on
math and [ __ ] right ready to go I
mean the Nazis gave meth to the soldiers
before war yeah because they would stay
awake they could be jacked up I mean why
wouldn't you take meth with your partner
dude fine why they lost the war they
were all hi I'm gonna suck their own
dicks in the bunkers man I don't know
math makes you got a sec ah yeah it does
okay trust me I don't do coke anymore
mess cured me of my code problem okay so
I your 15 your brother can bowl yes so
my brother take wheat dad takes me and
of course my brother named Karen it's my
birthday just hansung my ass in bowling
bowling can you bowl I I used to be able
to really Bowl because I camp not
anymore I like re beat me in a bowling
competition cereal sorry for being you
and a boy i got off am I supposed to
fight him at ellis mania in vegas we're
supposed to have a boxing martial arts
but yeah my brother could be me right
out to Gay in my dad never ever tried to
hide how pleased he was right how good
my brother was right and how he was
whooping my ass is your brother also
just at favorite period compared to you
guys wow I'm the only one to return
phone call okay got 10 so my pocket oh
yeah my brother's you know my brothers
like wandering the world trying to
figure out his life like there is
something about peeking yeah in like a
pray where he was like the best of the
best and now it's like and he could have
gone he could have gone pro bowling but
I just didn't want to do it yeah he was
whooping my ass what my my dad could
still beat him yeah but my brother was
the best he was feeding my
it was like a horrible way to start your
[ __ ] birthday it's not a cool way
yeah it's like it's my birth and make it
kind of close right yeah and it's like
15 which is my dad really let me knew
that this is the last year I would never
I didn't have a job this is like we
gotta here and then you're going to work
and I'm not paying for anything anymore
was your your dad your dad was in your
life as I mean he's still my life yes I
just want to i went to the haha cafe
just walked into the christmas party and
they gave me a ticket literally as soon
as they hand me a ticket I they drew my
number I want to join television I'm
going to give it to my guy saw that on
your Instagram yeah I literally walked
in and they just pulled my hammy ticket
they pulled it and you got a giant TV I
just I I'm like where should I go saying
joking and nobody wanted to help me
because people want the [ __ ] it down
yeah sure so I literally just I'm just
gonna pick the one right in the [ __ ]
middle Billy oh man boom TV 33 inch
television hearts awesome where's your
dad live he lives in I wish I could tell
you some stuff about my dad but he lives
in Prescott and I he calls me from the
office and the office is uh the the
Indian casino then he Gamble's that
every [ __ ] night okay my dad is
living a life of a college kid he's just
banging black chicks and [ __ ] playing
poker and that's all he's got you just
turned on my college bag in black chicks
is black book she used to date we got a
bit woman he he's dating right now you
should dance on Soul Train which is
shout out to yes right much less motion
yeah funky chicken that was her claim
the same and now she [ __ ] gave my dad
diabetes oh [ __ ] this is having that
black diet yeah everything's they aren't
you so what the [ __ ] your brother's
kicking your ass you're 50 50 otherwise
than waffles I was thinking of Roscoe's
chicken along with which by the way I
love as well yeah I love it over 80 try
that's what i need hot sauce on
everything so [ __ ] dry oh so i go to
it iron how I so I go and my brother
just hands to my ass yes is the star of
this birthday yeah so uh even though I'm
15 I'm still kind of into collecting
baseball cards yeah
I used to collect it I mean like real me
and my buddy Tony yeah we would just
subtly shout out Tony yeah tell you by
the way when i became a hardcore
christian oh like yeah it's so
interesting but that's a different
podcast but uh we would collect i mean i
still have them all the all the cards at
home all these amazing cards um so there
was a big baseball card like exhibit
going on that day and my dad's like i'll
take it down yeah you already lost at
bowling all right lost and polling
licking my wounds yep so my dad takes me
this thing and it's like I'm in heaven
there's all the cards their numbers he's
not that one is on us all these things
think I'll i love card I don't even
think I liked baseball but I like
baseball cards the only fun when you
were a kid I'm good I'm little dernier
the key keep the thing was to find a ken
griffey jr. yeah he was going to be the
great one and he still ended up being
great but last eight years diminished it
yeah sounds like hockey was great swing
and focus ya kid yes just a kid ed yeah
i mean the gray spaceball game I ever
saw in my life was the only time Don
manly ever made it to post season with
the Yankees because he was before Don
Steinberg decided to buy everybody right
and they finally made it and it was up
against Randy Johnson Ken Griffey jr.
and the Seattle Mariners and it was that
huge game you were at that game no I
watch on TV I remember watching I was so
big because it was like dominantly
finally made yeah the [ __ ] playoff man
like the mustache is in yeah and he's
going up against a giant Randy Johnson I
remember you like this guy that's when I
realized how like playoff baseball the
rest of season could just be set on fire
it correct so place playoff baseball is
just like such chess every pitch every
base runner every signal has
significance and meaning which is the
complete opposite of the regular season
that's right it's so fun exactly call
some guy from dribble I mean cited the
catcher does even other [ __ ] signals
half the time playoff baseball is so fun
right so good man i was just so i'm so
happy for Donnie baseball yeah
Bob you know I so you're at this
baseball convention yeah a baseball card
are vanishing grabbing everything I see
a Michael Jordan rookie card whoa this
is like this is 87 dog yeah he's already
kind of established that this is gonna
be his League yep I look at the card
mint condition yeah fifty dollars for
Michael Jordan rookie yeah well yes I
mean the picture the ABA I always loved
it and it wasn't even like a great
picture cuz they didn't really know who
was gonna be great they just you know
you had a feeling yeah Michael Jordan's
gonna do something great yeah because he
just broke and he's like he had a sink
rebel rookie season had it down period
then he had another one yeah yeah he was
anointed at this correct correct correct
87 yes and I go dad it's my birthday
yeah buy me the [ __ ] car Jordan
rookie Jordan rookie it's only fifty
dollars yeah this thing should be worth
a billion [ __ ] dollars yeah yeah yeah
now not going to do it dad it's my
birthday you never have to buy me
another birthday I'm about to turn 16
he's slowly never gonna buy me anything
after that right yeah cuz you gotta get
a [ __ ] job after this did I bought my
own car [ __ ] draw a flop boom just
and you just got on fire that was my
history my life you just but he just
bought i just bought a card 16 it's
literally the engine blew up as i left
did they [ __ ] return 0 they were scum
bag i had to go fight this [ __ ] dude
so can't buy it nope you know dad I
think he bought me like a Sally sandy
alomar card for like eight [ __ ]
dollars yeah that card today is now
worth seven grand I was gonna ask erin
to look it up Michael Jordan rookie is
now worth 7k 6780 three dollars Jesus
Christ why was the guy sonic we think it
was fake no dude it was like was Jackie
today yeah and gone on that crazy run
yeah yeah and that he just blew it up
and it's just like I remember going dad
this is the card you I'm like you cheap
[ __ ] can you sell I know it's worth 7k
but can you actually sell it for 7k so
buy it yeah some 17 k yeah like I was
just on my friend shall we were talking
about Stadium events it's the video game
have you heard about the zone no game
though it's like they only made twelve
thousand copies of it okay and word is
it only got sold in one nostrums and
there's still a debate whether that
happened right and it never really got
out and it's so [ __ ] rare to find one
it's a video game it's a video game and
that it's if you find one it's what
worth about 50 grand and the box itself
just stadium game the box yeah it
Stadium events it's 10 grand if you can
find your socks and if you have one
email me Michael Michael casa.com get it
going so he didn't buy that yeah so that
was the big thing so lost and bowling
dad won't buy a [ __ ] your dad just
lost six thousand nine hundred and fifty
dollars yeah yeah well as a kid I'm
[ __ ] down 6 Red man [ __ ]
ridiculous so then are then I decided my
mom wanted to my mom even though I'm 15
I was still gonna have some friends over
yeah we're gonna do a little sleepover
that's because we got in Sega or
Nintendo and we we had mike tyson's
punch all of them just got Mike Tyson's
punch-out look so a lot of a lot of
sports in your life I've loved sports I
mean by boiling to start baseball
bombing you just I never liked your
guesses is the punch drunk yeah that's
right yeah and where can people listen
to them you can go itunes everywhere
check punch-drunk sports where are you
Jason Tebow myself it's great our
network is about the launch next year
we're in we're working with all we're
like a branch now of all things comedy
yep we are a new website about to come
out hopefully in the new year and then
then we're supposed to get in a new
studio so we'll see what happened I cool
so so Mike Tyson's punch-out yes so we
get to my text so I'm gonna have a big
party yep and we've had the game for a
little while I have a big party fight a
couple guys over my friends Tony this
guy named Jeff couple other [ __ ] people
yeah ah it's a pizza sleepover yep
so they come over to the classics right
lasek did love two people yeah I do yeah
you had to do that I guess I just like
this birthday very much had a vibe of
stranger things like I'm just mad like
it was a very yeah you hung out in the
rec room yeah downstairs it was my my
dad decided just to make the downstairs
a hangout room love it panel all this
[ __ ] upstate New York you probably had
basements right why don't you pick
Michigan like the basement was the [ __ ]
just good shady don't hide hide liquor
in a wood [ __ ] my dad minister would
because he wanted to have we had a
fireplace so we'd have to throw would
that like our chores and punishment was
a hundred pieces of wood I'm so pissed
well he's got nothing failed to do [ __ ]
that's a Tschida [ __ ] hallwood
homeboy [ __ ] would first day of
summer vacation my sophomore year in
high school my dad said hey you see that
like meadow in that forest and I go yeah
and he goes this summer you're gonna
clean that out and it was like oh [ __ ]
that's for two months me and [ __ ]
Jimmy Meeks cleaned out the forest it
sucks out out Jimmy me I what everybody
all right so what's happening with mike
tyson's punch you know I'll get to it so
we order smoking we the best pizza in
the world is pudgy's pizza okay yeah
they used to do a 32 slice pizza holy
[ __ ] it was a giant sheet pizza you
never seen anywhere anymore well I don't
see those big party pizzas if you don't
dude in LA you don't you gotta [ __ ] you
papa johns for like a thing cross eight
slices like twenty dollars no I agree
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] man north east and
the Midwest know how to do [ __ ] party
a hundred new party beat cetera so
budgies pizza shout-out pudgy's it's
still the best someone just got shot
nice wiggle but that's not the point
where they're great pizza they order a
party pack huh they get it over right we
bring it in and my dog brandy get so
excited just on me knocks the pizza oh
ho [ __ ] falls my guests like [ __ ]
clean it up and we had be my dad
wouldn't get a new [ __ ] pizza better
put some water on that [ __ ] your dog
knocked the beats and you gotta eat it
Danny I mean you're not buying an extra
pc you're not buying another 32 piece
like like a four foot long Eddie recall
back leg baby legging I don't think
what's wrong with family hey helmet and
it was back in the day when you order
mushrooms and you couldn't see the pizza
you just got grey you got a nine sheet
of grey now your order pizza it's like
one mushroom on each line I hate that
[ __ ] click I got Hawaiian the other day
and it was like one of the pieces didn't
even have pineapple on it sounds like
it's just rude give me some [ __ ]
Hawaiian Sun we're doing so you know my
pizza gets knocked over yeah and I got
to eat the pita like my dad jail now my
dad's yelling five-second rule right you
know yourself yep yeah sounds like a
shitty birthday like I said this was
traumatizing I keep waiting for you to
be like molested it gets okay okay so
then we're eating a pizza and we're
playing we're playing a videogame yep
and I keep going hey Jeff ya wanna go on
plays like now I'm good I must I must
stay here on the couch stays on the
couch okay never moves the whole night
I'm like weird look Jessica to [ __ ] off
the weird nah dude I'm good stays there
for play we're playing my brother comes
down he wants to play Mike Tyson's
punch-out no and apparently he's been
playing a lot cuz he [ __ ] beats my
god damn i'm mike tyson he beats my i
still can't beat that the [ __ ] guy he
[ __ ] beats Mike Tyson that's my
brother always been like beets Mike
Tyson I'm on another rockin yeah
birthday dog you know meacham to our way
it's my breath I got one thing to do and
have to beat that kids ass yeah I to
beat my used to be my brother up so much
we would make up new wrestling
federation's for him sanibel up ya ghali
igg see how do weight champion did you
kick the [ __ ] out of your brother all
the time Gustad my brother three years
old he's gonna kick the [ __ ] out of me
it still in fact because he talks mad
[ __ ] the bagel just bring your tune
whenever you're I still close with your
brother yes I'm very close he he
sometimes drives me [ __ ] nurse that's
your family but it is family but I do
love him to death and we're very close
and he's wandering the earth right now
well he went on the street where he just
ran strip
and he was so happy but my brother
always wants to be like steve jobs
tomorrow like you want to get hired they
give all things comedy hired him he'd
wanted at BL magical tomorrow right like
he has no clue it's about like how to
move up yeah like he doesn't like every
he's the but he is we're so similar and
we're so different we were like he's
great in offices he knows how to work
stop yeah but he can't sit there and be
like okay i'll just wait some
intervention get my he wants to run an
impatient one hundred percent and that's
how he's always been so yeah i used to
beat his ass right yeah well my mom sees
that we're fighting and she ends the
[ __ ] birthday she ends the [ __ ]
birthday cuz i just beat my ass my
brothers had made him [ __ ] clue she
kicks everybody out he got go home it's
just I'm sorry shot your parents we had
a mergency over there everybody's gotta
go to [ __ ] home Jeff gets up from the
bed runs out from the couch he [ __ ] his
pants and didn't get off the [ __ ]
couch and he [ __ ] dog couch smelled
like ass hole and I had to my mom had to
air it out for two days why that's why
he wasn't standing up that's why he
wasn't good now I has anyone [ __ ]
their pants at age 15 I don't know man
don't mess with death I Guinness Book
not make no I don't think so he [ __ ] his
pants yeah I think it was the pizza that
Brandis maybe rather on it which is the
brandy breath pizza so recap brother
beat you in bowling dad doesn't buy you
Michael Jordan rookie cards I mean come
on dad that's a big mistake morson best
whatever mike tyson's punch up brother
comes down beats Mike Tyson you kick his
ass mom cancels the party Jeff shits
himself that is disgusting yeah I love
that your mom also aired the couch up 42
day she didn't throw the couch away no
she aired it out did anybody sing a
happy birthday you think I think so how
did this birthday affect you you think
in your life if it did um I mean did it
help you tell a good story you tell
great stories now
you think maybe I never really told that
story before really yeah I should I
don't really go back and tell like the
kids stories and before and when I asked
you about worst birthday that did pop
into your brain well not interesting
yeah that and the other one in vague is
a funny thing about my mom she literally
wanted me to have a babysitter until I
was like in tenth grade is that right
like how [ __ ] funny is that if I were
to ask your mom about your 15th birthday
which she would you remember that I
don't know if she remembered that one
but she would remember that Jeff [ __ ]
the she would remember that yes is weird
that he [ __ ] himself thank you I'd never
[ __ ] yourself yeah you have you know
Aaron gingers I don't I've gotten no i
mean i remember i was driving a rooster
t feathers up in sunnyvale and i got
pretty close I dude I just [ __ ] my black
bull [ __ ] dude I viewed the other day my
[ __ ] was just holding on like [ __ ]
behind line yeah right and I had to go
to I [ __ ] at the Makai like last week at
three nights and all I [ __ ] in the
McDonald's because I couldn't get home
in time right and I always tell
ourselves if I I put my I like I I got
into the bathroom I didn't even look my
just jumped on the toilet and dropped it
yeah and as soon as I dropped I felt
water on my ass and I'm like what the
[ __ ] I look down the toilets already
flooded oh [ __ ] but now there's now but
it's a sensor it's a movement sensor
date right I'm having some weird like
saw moment damned if I do damned if I
don't if I [ __ ] move it's going to
flood over if I don't move i'm stuck
here who stuck on a toilet yeah that
nothing has been more detrimental to the
human bathroom experience than motion
sensor it's never works never find then
you go to the [ __ ] phone and it
doesn't ever real I've never never
reached it Jeff if you're listening and
you remember this event where you [ __ ]
yourself reach out to us using hashtag
worst bday pod or email me Michael at
Michael Kosta com or check out Sam where
Sam where people find out your
information
I'm at on every social media at Sam
Tripoli TR IPO li ya then youtube.com
backslash Sam trips and Tripoli if I
were to ask you your favorite or best
birthday right now designing coming to
mind well on my 21st birthday I was
blackout drunk by nine o'clock okay and
it was fun it was fun I mean like I've
had some good I mean like my college
years a great birthday after that I mean
Dana my girlfriend i've been with
forever you should throw me surprise
parties all the time very funny she
threw me a bowling party tales awesome
yeah I have a lot of social anxiety yeah
and really be up dude it's bad I like
really especially that I'm sober it's
like it's been the hardest part of being
so we're probably the drinking help to
help on the blow help you around blow
your Vince Neil motley crue [ __ ] 85
bro you're like who wants a business
plan you know we're building a roller
coaster all right so you got some social
anxiety okay so I just don't like them I
really have a real problem of bothering
people okay especially in this town
that's the worst thing like i watch
friends mine Tony his clip just go up
and ask for [ __ ] constantly unbelievable
and it's just like and you know what
maybe doesn't get everything but he gets
a lot of it I have a friend of New York
and New Yorkers are extra pushy but he's
like you got to ask for what you want
and he's right but that's that's not how
I just wasn't raised like that i'm not i
just don't want bothering anybody and i
have an ego where it's like yeah I don't
want but like two people I know they do
it a lot get a lot of [ __ ] you don't we
do get a lot of [ __ ] we just before you
came here we had Henry Phillips here and
oh he's Christ great he's hilarious he's
fantastic and he's another example of
just an understated very successful a
very funny comedian and it's like how
was white why is he not on an amy
schumer level and then but you know it's
a lot a lot of [ __ ] but he I could see
him not asking i could see him not put
you know and it's just a channel i think
he's wonderful I thought if I movies
were all right I said club he's such a
nice dude yeah but you know man it's
like you know that Amy shoe
like you watch what she's going through
right now I mean duh we all want to be
huge but do we really want that I mean
like it just seems like right now he's a
pinata yeah it is yeah yeah I'm as you
also post these [ __ ] Instagram posts
of like I'm proud of my body and then
it's like nine thousand words and I'm
like you know I'm not a woman I can't
relate but it's also like okay great
nice nice blog post I guess I I don't
even know like women and their [ __ ]
it's just like so I mean we just
everything going back everybody's pain
is unique that's what they want a
correct it's like well you're kind of
where you are because you are a [ __ ]
fake [ __ ] you know just a [ __ ] true
food it's like it's just like the young
people want to like certain things
happen and it's just like the problem
with me is I I just can't get anyone I
have no group I'm like Boba Fett dude
I'm like a lone assassin your Good Sam
you're good you know what you're funny I
was just listening to someone said bill
burr bill burr put it best he's so good
so the best thing ever said was when
you're not famous in a comic every show
is an away game run your father a famous
Harry shows a home game and last night
that gay bar I was an away game your
plan so all the reps are [ __ ] call
and traveling on you even though you
weren't traveling the ticky tack fouls
yeah it's very but that's also why I say
we but that's why you get good you're
playing an away game every [ __ ] night
for 20 years and then eventually when it
becomes a home game you got it I can
tell you this you got it I feel like I
am working at the best I've ever worked
in turn my premises yep I just feel like
it's it's the hardest I've ever had to
work yeah more than ever yeah maybe it's
because when I was young I was just
talking about dropping all that dick on
everybody cuz you know because that's
what my life was yeah and now it's like
I'm just like okay I'm older I'm dealing
with older we gotta deal with other [ __ ]
now i'm watching all my friends slowly
become conservatives like I so weird
it's like my buddy's like hey dude you
ever watch Bill O'Reilly I'm like what
you know so just an interesting things
but yeah i just feel like i'm working
the my new albums about to come out
about a month and a half where can we
get it it's gonna be everywhere it's
called a diabolical look at who's to CD
album like first ones me crushing and
then the last one is called friday night
lay show where it's just like that drunk
sloppy crowd and i'm just about five
minutes in this thing I realized this is
unrecorded ball and I just started going
on be well where where is recorded we at
the Sacramento punchline a lot of great
alike hey tech i'm like i love i love
that that's always a fun Club next to
the mattress shop Sacramento is the most
underrated city bad campa are so
underrated because it's just like they
come there to laugh yeah they're having
fun they don't take [ __ ] too seriously
meanwhile San Francisco they're so in
their own head they you tell a dick joke
and they don't laugh cuz they're like
we're above that it's like guys just
relax man I don't just just [ __ ]
relax and watch some of their people who
they I mean like there's no bigger dick
joke comic then [ __ ] louis ck yeah
there's no big i mean i remember
watching David crosses hello I'm like
this page filthy yeah why was this guy
old cuz you wear glasses yeah city looks
already yeah he's funny and it's just
like because you look like them as they
love if the law comes down to do you
know it's like the progressive left of
the 2016 is exactly like the religious
right of the [ __ ] in early 90s I've been
losing Twitter followers because I've
been tweeting hey la Coastal's you're
you're as shitty as my [ __ ] Michigan
militia friends yeah you're literally as
terrible and I literally watch [ __ ]
340 people leave my Twitter but I'm just
like I'm so sick of it it's McCarthy
yeah dude if you really think about what
McCarthyism was it was a witch chase to
destroy people that in the end of the
day it really wasn't what they believe
they just don't like them fit and that's
how they apply political correctness if
they don't like you you you like if
Lewis seek I believe Larry the Cable Guy
did half the joke Sarah Silverman did
they was already know
oh yeah me too because Troy I mean it's
just like as no it has to do with I like
you and I've said before I'm Rogan's
podcast but the truth is everybody just
wants a world that place of their
strength echogenic outlaws their
weaknesses echo chamber and we just see
like if you watch Amy Schumer she's
doing everything a guy does bang way out
of her league pocket you know hang out
with more famous people and you know
it's just the same [ __ ] thing ladies
and gentlemen Sam Tripoli he's got
opinions on everything I might talk too
much i love this absolutely not
absolutely favorite park as i doing just
no no by the way you know you you run a
podcast you love when the guest has [ __ ]
to say I love it I love it I've been on
your podcast it's super fun you should
come back on dude anyway I asked any
time last time I did your podcast I went
to the wrong [ __ ] place yeah that's
science center I mean this time sounds
can be on one Street I was like at the
wrong foot ladies and gentlemen please
check out is it Sam Tripoli com yeah I
mean I don't update that yeah okay but
all is social is Sam Tripoli and check
out punch punch drunk sports on the all
things calming network thank you for
sharing anytime thank you for having me
on dude I appreciate you're my favorite
thanks Sam Sam Tripoli you guys check
him out on youtube instagram is funny
twitter october 28 that Michael Jordan
rookie card for fifty bucks what's it
worth now Erin about six thousand
dollars Wow 13 years ago was a pristine
copy went for a hundred grand are you
[ __ ] serious yes Sam's dad you just
you just lost a hundred grand more or
less funny how he this guy has opinions
dude and I love talking to Sam I mean I
just ended the podcast and then he stays
in you know 20 minutes telling us about
how Russia didn't actually hack Hillary
Clinton's emails and the CIA flooded the
ghettos with crack I mean he's just got
opinions and I [ __ ] love listening to
him
and if anyone out there that seen Sam
Tripoli live you don't forget it man
he's he's funny and he's subversive and
it's just it's great stuff so please
check it out I I always enjoyed Sam and
I'm thankful but he hired me for his
game show called squabble which
hopefully you guys will see eventually
this is michael kosta and we're doing
the worst birthday podcast on the all
things comedy network you can always
check out this podcast and many other
great podcasts at all things comedy calm
and you can listen to every single one
of my podcast episodes at worst birthday
calm and if you're an Amazon shopper
sorry it's been a long day my brain is
kind of fried if you're an Amazon shop
or go to worst birthday calm click on
our amazon banner ad and do your
shopping and then give this a little
kickback which helps run this podcast so
thank you for that tweet us using
hashtag worst bday pod or hashtag worst
birthday you can find all of my live
dates at Michael Kosta com if you leave
a review on soundcloud stitcher or
itunes please leave your instagram or
your Twitter handle in the review and I
will gladly personally shout out five
stars is always appreciated it goes a
long way thank you very much everybody
every Thursday a new worst birthday
podcast happy holidays or whatever
you're celebrating happy worst birthday
thanks guys
[Music]